so you probably heard that old adage
that every person has at least one good
book in them I believe in something
grander than that I believe that every
great person has at least one great beer
all they need is a fearless brewer like
me so when I say the word brewer you
probably don't think fashion it probably
conjures up images of some fat guy in
lederhosen but actually the worlds of
designing clothes and designing beers is
very very similar in both cases you're
just taking some natural ingredients or
materials and combining them in a way
that you hope makes you stand out from
the pack and I'm meeting with a couple
brothers who definitely are stand out
from the pack these days brothers Emil
and Sandee casillo
were just named gqueues best new
menswear designers in America for 2015
and they're in the final stages of
opening a flagship store for their brand
that he'll son before they are making
salvaged denim Tuen tailored jacket
stuff they made their name with a line
of square bottom ties that served as a
blank canvas
for their mastery of Japanese textiles
and colorful fabric dyes
you know the oftentimes that openings
beverages are served you know how about
we do a hillside beer do we have time
shopping in a few weeks Oh some styles
of beer we can make this happen
it couldn't do like a German lager a
commercial Pilsener type of thing but
there's some nice kind of rough raw
beers that I think would go well so
right the concept is if you're cool with
it is with your guys prowess with colors
I want to do one based beer and take it
in this different vibrant directions
with colors as we can cool why don't we
go downstairs to the to the basement of
the shop we've got some stuff we've been
working on we can check the color stuff
yeah it's not no we've got we've got
some natural dyes to show you and a guy
with a gym ball before coming here today
the guys and I traded a few ideas about
how to translate their design aesthetic
into a tasty adult beverage they
immediately suggested we merge the
process of making clothes and making
beer by utilizing all natural edible
dyes that can be used for both fabric
and liquid so cool we got some little
R&D that you guys are putting together
yeah here we've got four different
vegetable natural pigments we've been
sort of just started playing with yeah
that we think could also taste good
we've got carrots matcha is ground-up
Japanese green tea wild green one yeah
and then blackberries and blueberries
can we see the intensity of these and
yeah
yeah we'll try it out yeah
I'm really curious to see to find out
what a beer with caricatures yak Barry
what do you think of reddish purplish
color I'm guessing this is gonna be less
intense than these two yeah I'm pretty
sure we're gonna try blueberries it's a
superfood actually kind of want to see
what this is right away you can see it's
a little bit more purple but we got to
know how they are gonna taste in a beer
you know so I know we only got weeks to
leopa Nate let's brew this beer in
Brooklyn great cool so I'm buddies with
you guys no other half yeah yeah great
hoppy beers yeah let's load up
ingredients I already put the call out
to them they're expecting us cool so
they're actually heating their water now
great wicked
we got like an hour to get there okay
the other half Murray opened in 2014 and
in his head hot Headz lining up around
the block
ever since owner Sam and Matt are busy
as hell but they were kind enough to
free up some space in the brew kettle
and help this brew come to life
in Brooklyn nice thank you guys for
letting us come in here with your world
absolutely happy to have you hopefully
put this period pretty fast there how
many weeks a few a few weeks a few weeks
still opening I know you guys do amazing
hoppy beers that probably need a bunch
of dry-aging time but I know you're no
strangers to saison XY's all right no
definitely not
basically we want to build a beer that's
a awesome canvas for colors because
we've been playing around with some dyes
in their world we want to see if we can
bring the dyes together with a beautiful
beer yeah sounds good to us because this
is a hard part of our job we start
drinking and I sit in there
trying stuff you got plenty of beer
let's hunker down and put some guys
here
face beer guys what do we got
just for experimenting today we're using
a basically a pale session that we do
call hopped in full turns of love a bond
it's pretty similar to what we'll be
looking at with the saison yeast but
it's got a bit more clarity to it so we
could really get an idea of what the
colors are gonna look like the love of
on scale is a way to measure color in
brewing since our goal is to let the
dyes shine through in the liquid we need
our base beer to be on the lighter end
of the love of on spectrum is the
blueberry
push Brewers take the percent you don't
die
Green so it looks like bigger volume of
the green would be needed your final
color I think this stuff is pretty
potent Wow your first time definitely
pick up Karen in there yeah okay so you
guys are in the driver's seat you got a
bunch of Brewer passengers with their
seatbelts on next to you saying where
are you taking us for me I think that
the blueberry and the carrot of them are
together the matcha is the like from a
flavour point of view is the most
contentious so we got our choices on
dyes which is awesome all right gents we
got a we got our marching orders as
Brewers right so is it time should we go
mash in it's nice - yeah this is always
good our turnovers for the hillside
broom we've chosen a saison for two
reasons first saison yeast ferments warm
and quickly which will help us get our
gear ready for the hillside opening and
most importantly it's a versatile style
that allows us to use rice and other
light-colored grains that won't have
scale the raw vibrant colors of
blueberry and carrots
gqueues best menswear designers 2015
have spent the last three weeks
crankin to get their flagship store open
for business while their multi-coloured
beers for men now it's the moment of
truth
brothers Emil and Sandee invited some
New York fashion industry friends to
help Chris in the shop and serve as the
ultimate judges for which color reigns
supreme
so this is it culmination of a grand
experiment we are at the hillsides grand
opening here in Brooklyn other half
dogfish hillside through this
collaborative beer together actually two
three weeks ago I did not have this
mustache three weeks ago these beers
didn't exist one blank canvas two colors
of paint carrots and blueberries let's
see which ones people prefer all right
you guys I am in trying to get yeah so
you guys don't tell us anything no
preferences cheers guys looks like a
sunset looks like a hot rock sunset yeah
grapefruit juice
Oh carrots they're the fries that's a
good beer guys well done it's so good
yeah who wants to try the blueberry I
don't do it all right blue blue this for
sure it was super acidic like tasting
just a pure a winner
projects like this are labors of love
and you can taste the love guys I can't
make up my mind which I like no it's not
really up top what do you - what do you
guys think what's your favorite yeah I
think I gotta go carrots a lot of my
morning routine juicing the carrot is
placed in this world but it does make me
feel like I should be across there or
something I think I'm going carrot you
guys got to make sure to vote I actually
like the blueberry she has a little bit
more soul and like
last chance to vote the carrot has more
of a WOW factor
my friends I think I might have to go
with a blueberry if I had my way I was
great news all right we're gonna do it
count them up all right guys all right
here we go
1 2 3 4 5 6 12 13 14 21 to 23 are you
sure
23 carats Sam cut the blue all right
2 6 10 12 16 20 is that close yeah I
love both so it's equally critical that
you give amazing names to both the hair
the names they love the boat and this is
it we're gonna thing about the carrot
beer we were thinking about growing up
watching cartoons and Elmer Fudd will
always say it's wabbit season and we
decided to call the beer it's wabbit
says on the way over fun would say it
another one for the blueberry beer we
went in a really weird inside joke and
hillside makes a lot of blue stuff
indigo dye is a big part of our
collection you walk around the hillside
store you see a lot of blue and no so we
get we got some beef from somebody on
Facebook sayings too much blue though he
spelled two wrong he misspelled
two just tio so instead of too much blue
like we make too much blue and said it's
too much blue
turns out the flavors we chose to these
brews weren't just destined to
consumption in our Grand Opening gear it
just goes to show how committed to their
craft Emile and CND really are they went
the extra mile and they made a limited
line of t-shirts died carrot and
blueberry